first of all thanks for coming my name's
Steve Allen she her and I'm super happy
to be here this is my third strange Loop
and it's been a minute since I was here
last but I'm very excited to talk to you
today about regular Expressions just as
a quick survey how many people in the
room have not ever used regular
expressions in their day-to-day job
okay that's interesting I'm going to
talk to you after you're after the
session
um
uh how many people in here have ever
wondered where the Syntax for regular
Expressions comes from
okay that's awesome and how many of you
have ever wondered about the differences
between different implementations of
regular expression engines
oh great well I can assure you that by
the time we're done with this talk that
you will leave the room well informed
about all of those things so
um as I said I just want to do an
overview of what we're going to talk
about today we are definitely going to
talk about regular Expressions we're
going to talk about the sort of origin
and theory and Foundation like the
mathematical Foundation of of regular
Expressions we're going to talk about
deterministic and non-deterministic
um I've been saying this word wrong I
guess it's automata
I'm not sure I say automata
I don't I've heard different people say
different things to me so I don't know
which one is the right one but if I mess
it up just I'm sorry
um and then also we're going to talk
about editors because reasons
um I'll get into that in the talk
um and then finally we're going to talk
about feral regular Expressions these
are regular Expressions that will cut
you
um and so we're going to talk about why
they do that and how they do that
um but anyway let's get started so the
first place we're going to stop is with
these two old gentlemen the guy over
here on the left his name is
um uh Walter Pitts and he is actually a
logician
um and he worked with people like Alonso
Church
um who you may have heard of if you're
especially if you're a functional
programming nerd like me and then the
guy on the other side there is uh Warren
McCulloch and he is a neurophysicist and
together they wrote this paper in 1943
called a logical calculus of the ideas
eminent and nervous activity and what
this was what this paper describes is a
mathematical model for how biological
neurons work so the ideas they presented
in this paper are really interesting
sorry excuse me um so one the first
thing that they found out is that there
is sort of um well the way that they
created their mod let me back up the way
they created their model is they had all
these sort of biological components of a
neuron right so there's like this Axiom
there's a ganglia there's like an input
receptor area right so there's all these
biological structures and they all have
different properties but what they
boiled it down to in the math model that
they created for all of this is a couple
of basic things one thing is that there
is a binary state for nervous cells
they're either on or they're off okay so
that's Point number one point number two
is is that there is an excitation uh
phase when a neuron fires and the way
the neuron fires is there is like this
summation equation that happens so
there's this sort of sequence of input
into a neuron and it reaches a threshold
and when that threshold is reached the
neuron changes its state from off to on
so that's second point the third point
is stop
this model contains another inhibitor
and what that is is another input signal
to the neuron that says no matter how
much input you get you are always in the
off State okay so it's a way for the
neuron to stop being activated by any
kind of input that it receives
subsequent to getting that inhibitor so
this paper was written in 1943 and it
was really interesting paper it kind of
just sat there for a long time and then
this guy came along you may have heard
of him especially if you're like into
sort of theoretical computer science and
again here's another name that I've
heard different ways that people say it
Wikipedia says that his name is like
Clinic I'm not really sure that's right
everyone I've ever talked to says his
name is cleaney anyway Steven cleaney
was a logician a mathematician and a
theoretical computer scientist his
thesis advisor was Alonso church as well
so Alonso church is like a pretty big
guy like in the history of fundamental
computer science things
also
cleaning is really famous for kind of
creating the mathematical basis for
recursion and again if you're a
functional programming nerd like me
um then recursion is very near and dear
to your heart
um so he's responsible for all that you
can lay that all at his feet
um and I you know I take some comfort in
that
um but anyway in 1951 he wrote this
paper for the Rand project which was
Project the United States Air Force and
what he was trying to do was model
um neurons model neurons in a sort of a
mechanical or electronic way and so he
found this paper that was written in
1943 that we just talked about and he
was like well okay
um as a thought experiment what if there
was an electronic way for us to simulate
neurons and then arrange them in
networks right how would that work what
would that be like and then on top of
that
um you know he came up with this notion
of a state machine you know which he
called something like a regular event
and there's also the idea of the the
I'm going to say it wrong again automata
about
someone help me
yeah okay yeah screw you guys
um
[Laughter]
automata it's in it's in the paper and
he describes the mathematical basis so
he created an algebra for all these
different things
um and he also included this idea of a
regular event he didn't call it an
expression he called it an event but
they're really synonymous like the terms
are mathematically defined in such a way
that if you look at the mathematical
definition for an expression and you
look at the mathematical definition for
an event they are actually The Identical
uh things so he described this in this
paper for 1951 and he wrote this algebra
here and I just briefly want to cover it
so this algebra has three operations in
it
um
and because they didn't have litek in
1951 you get like hand-drawn symbols
over here on the slide so um there's the
e or F right that's one operation so you
can think of that as like alternation
right
um there's EF which is concatenation
which is e followed by F right everyone
with me so far and then finally there's
this e star F and everyone's like well
what is a star like Professor cleaning
like what is a star
um and I mean I'm sure you're all
familiar with the star operator right
who knows what the star operator is
go ahead shout it out
yeah zero or more right so in a set of
in a set of of symbols a cleaning star
represents zero more symbols from that
set right
um so that's also another operator
that's in this algebra so this paper
describes all those terms and all those
operators and it lays the mathematical
foundations for all those different
things
um and again this was all theoretical
there were like no Computing devices
that could really tackle this problem in
1951.
um but that was soon to change because
time sharing became a thing later in
that decade so toward the end of the 50s
there was some more work that was done
this is another really important paper
so this idea of automata got like borne
out into the world
um and it floated around for a while and
people were like hey this is a really
neat idea like what can we use
um this idea to model okay and something
that came up right away was
well we're going to use it to model
reading input off of a tape
okay because paper tape was a thing
um I know it's it's hard to believe but
it was a thing and um uh so that's what
they started doing with it and um there
was a guy who worked at IBM research
um this guy named Rabin and he wrote
this paper called uh finite automata and
their decision problems and in this
paper he describes a situation where
um the uh input that's given to these
automatic cannot be decided right
there's a decision problem there where
you fundamentally cannot actually move
forward with a computation and so he
shows the mathematical proofs of this
and all the underlying algebra how it
falls apart when you start considering
the case where you have more than one
input to the same machine
um and so he came up with some solutions
for this and
um there was like this bifurcation in
these in these State machines and there
was this idea of deterministic and
non-deterministic automata right so on
the one side you had the deterministic
automata and here are the properties of
that particular device right
each state transition is uniquely
determined by its source State okay and
a symbol that gets read in by some
mechanism and then also another property
of this system is that an input symbol
is required for each transition so um
you know you can kind of Imagine like in
your head that this a really
straightforward way you look at the next
sequence or sorry the next item in the
sequence you look at your internal state
that you're dealing with and you decide
am I going to update my state or not
right and this is a obvious like
corollary to or analog to writing a
program right this is really what we're
kind of doing when we're writing
programs is we're updating State and
controlling State and things like that
okay so the advantage of having these
types of devices devices here is now in
air quotes is that they're easy to
program right like you can very easily
imagine a straightforward implementation
that has the exact same behavior as one
of these devices but the drawback is is
that you have a huge amount of State
explosion even with a very small number
of symbols because you have all these
different possibilities for every single
symbol that you're reading off of your
input and so there has to be a better
way to do it right and so the other
thing that this paper showed if I'm just
going to pop back to it really quick is
that all DFAS are also a specialized
superset sorry subset of of nfas the
non-deterministic type so he also I
showed again through math magic that I'm
not going to get in into here but if you
want to read it it's in that paper also
I just want to quickly shout out the ACM
like in the past I've kind of been
reluctant to cite ACM sources because
honestly like tracking these papers down
and you hit a paywall it makes you sad
but for all these kind of really old
papers the paywall has come down and so
you know thank you ACM yeah thank you
let's yeah thank you
um appreciate your applied Applause um
and and yeah keep that coming later and
um yeah so there's non-deterministic
ones and they are actually Encompass all
um all of these finite machines that are
out there in the world
um and that these deterministic ones
have these special properties they're
just kind of a tiny little special case
essentially
um all right so that was kind of the
state of the art in 1959
um and you know
it was an interesting thing like uh
there was a an algorithm that came out
in the in the early 60s by uh McNaughton
and Yamada which I'm not going to cover
here because I don't have time
um but that was kind of the state of the
art for about five years or so
and
um then this guy came along and many of
you probably know who this is
um there's a a very famous computer
scientist uh engineer
um just all around uh awesome guy who
came up with this expression algorithm
um and he described it in Communications
the ACM in 1968.
um and so this paper is super short I
highly recommend it it's like three
pages long it's like really uh easy to
digest easy to understand there's not a
lot of math in it there is a lot of
object code but you know if you are a
functional programming nerd like me then
you will like that so
um look this paper up again not behind a
paywall you can find it it's easy to
find it's really really fascinating all
right so I just wanted to do a really
practical example and show you what a
state diagram for a non-deterministic
finite automata automata automata yes
that's it automata what it looks like
and so I'm going to go to my next slide
all right so
um
me Wander over here
all right up here in the corner I have
my Sigma and sigma is defined as in
alphabet of symbols and so my symbols
right now are ABCD right everyone with
me so far
awesome all right so below that I have
this regular expression
um and we're not going to worry about
like the syntax of that right now we're
we'll get into that in a few minutes
um but anyway what we're looking for
here is a and then maybe we're going to
look for B and maybe we're going to look
for C right and how many of those are we
going to find zero or more right because
that's the cleaning star and then we're
gonna end our our search with what a d
right we literally have to find an A and
A D we might find a b we might find a c
right that's the whole rules here and if
you look at the state diagram you can
see that if you start over here and you
kind of go through here there's this
like plus operator
and this plus operator has a really
interesting property which DFAS don't
have the nfas have this plus operator
and the plus operator has two arrows
coming out of it which means that it can
bifurcate that it can move into states
that are not formally allowed right
that's what that decision problem is
that I was talking about earlier so as
this thing searches through this set of
text right so I give it some input and
this job is to figure out does my input
match this expression right does it
match this thing and so we can move
through this state diagram very easily
and every time we encounter a plus we
can actually make many decisions right
so in this one in this case simple I
don't want to like overwhelm you all we
can make two decisions right but you can
imagine a case where we have a super
complex regular expression and we have a
ton of decisions like we have end
decisions to make
all right so we're going to start with a
phrase we're going to look for an a
we're going to hit this plus and then
we're going to maybe find a d that would
be cool right that would be a match
um or we can look at our next input
symbol and we can find a b that would
also be cool or we could find a c that
would also be cool
um and so those are our potential
choices right
okay everyone with me yeah question
it's it's that's a good question
actually thank you for asking that the
question was why are there two pluses
um it's a formalism that that Thompson
used in the paper
um just to keep things simple but just
for the just for the sake of answering
that question
um the pluses mean that we can have
multiple branches of decision making
okay in the paper he defines it very
strictly as two decisions
um but you can imagine that there's a
plus operator that takes n decisions
um yeah another question
all right
oh it's just a spacer it's just a spacer
it's not a syntax thing yeah it's just a
space yeah it's a spacer sorry yeah I'm
sorry that wasn't clear
um but yeah so at the bottom of the D
which is the final state that we can
find in our in our expression we have
you know the potential output right so
that's theoretically what we should find
if we follow the state diagram correctly
all right
so we're going to move on
I kind of just blew through my next
slide so you know I wanted to do this
whole thing like will it match you know
it's like will it blend it's not as cool
as blending an iPhone but you know I
don't really have an iPhone to blend for
you guys so
um anyway is AD gonna match yes of
course it's gonna match right okay so
now we have a plus a bunch of B's is
that going to match
no why
because it's not followed with a d right
well guess what I have I have an error
in my slides
um
okay and and finally it's the last thing
going to match why is it gonna match
right because the D's not in the right
place
right it's a d right and then we have
some other stuff there not gonna match
okay all right so Thompson concludes
this paper with this very intriguing
paragraph right he says this compiling
scheme is amenable to extensions hey
that's pretty interesting what kind of
extensions can we do uh well we can
introduce special characters that can be
matched situations or sequences like
beginning of line a character end of
lines any character Etc right there's a
whole bunch of operations here all right
so I'm going to take a short digression
um all right who has ever seen anything
on this slide before aside from words
obviously you've all seen words okay so
what do I have here I have a paper tape
right that's the one on the left and I
have a punch card
um and you know before time sharing was
really
um really common out in the world this
is the way that people interacted with
systems right they would create a
program on a paper tape they would run
it through a reader it would you know
put the stuff into memory and the
program would execute right that's how
they kind of did it or they'd have a
card deck and then they would feed the
cards in one at a time sequentially do
the same thing right and that would run
a program and there'd be some output
there was also card punches and paper
punches so computers actually could
output paper tapes and output card decks
too right because you could write you
could input your your program in like a
high level language like Fortran and
then it would like pop out object code
on a card deck right and you could take
that and go to some other computer and
run the same program or at least that
was a theory but anyway that was your
input output format when you're
operating in an environment like that
you don't really need to keep like
interactive state right and I have um
I've done I did a whole talk about the
history of time sharing before Unix
which is super interesting but
unfortunately I don't have time to get
into now but it wasn't really until time
sharing was a thing which was kind of
like the sort of middle to late 70s
sorry middle to late 60s
um there was a whole bunch of time
sharing systems that got developed kind
of simultaneously among the most famous
ones that you may have heard of is the
Berkeley time sharing system and there
was also one at MIT called ctss both of
those are super fascinating and then um
the sort of successor to that was this
thing called multix which you may have
heard of if you're like a Unix nerd and
this super super interesting guy named
Francisco corbado which I would love to
tell you about but I don't have time so
we'll just skip over that part but he's
online he's on Wikipedia it's a
fascinating story highly encourage you
to read it but the digression I'm
getting into here is for this an online
editor okay and so until time sharing
was a thing that people cared about you
just did paper tapes you did Punch Cards
you did paper tapes you didn't have this
sort of interactivity where you were
actually like literally sitting at a
physical typewriter or teletype or
whatever and and getting responses from
the runtime system right you would throw
your card deck in a in a in a you know a
bin and then someone would come and take
it and run it through the card reader
and later you would come find your
printout or a new card deck waiting for
you in the computer lab right that's how
people did computation anyway so there
was this paper It Was Written in 1967
and it was written by some people that
you may be familiar with especially if
you're into distributed systems this guy
named Peter Deutsch and also Butler
Lampson
um
and they described this editor that they
created for the Berkeley time sharing
system well the thing that's really
interesting about this paper is that Ken
Thompson the guy that we just talked
about in the last slides also was at
Berkeley the same time that this editor
was being wrote and he really liked it
and when he left Berkeley after his um
you know in it's not an internship but
it's like you know um I don't know what
they call he was like a visiting scholar
or whatever and when his when his time
at Berkeley was finished and he went
back to New Jersey and went back to Bell
labs and started working on multix he
was like you know what like this editor
that we had in California was amazing
and I'm going to rewrite it I'm going to
rewrite it for these systems that I use
all the time here in Murray Hill and um
you know I want to keep all the features
right I want to keep all the features
and this paper introduces a bunch of
things that modern text editor users
like you and like me take for granted
things like search strings things like
labeling parts of your program
um like input output buffers copy paste
buffers being able to edit pieces of a
line like selectively choose where you
want to edit at and align like all sorts
of stuff like that all described in this
paper
um oh my favorite thing about this paper
I didn't have time to to cut and show
you on a slide but the substitution
syntax the little s slash you know uh
what Target uh replacement
um slash like that whole thing that came
from this editor right it's listed in
this paper it is very cool this is a new
paper to read also super fascinating the
other thing I loved about this paper
honestly since I'm digressing so far
we're just going to go all the way down
that rabbit hole
I mean that's what you get with me is
like turtles all the way down
um so the thing that I really loved
about this was the physicality of this
um like in the in the paper
um uh Deutsch and Lampson describe how
the teletype advances forward so that
the output that the editor is changing
lines up with the previous line so like
if you're modifying
um a text string or whatever above like
you know the quick brown fox jumped over
the lazy dog whatever
um by the way I'm sorry uh the the
transcriptor person like sorry about
that
um
so
so
um the the uh the the
um this this this editor QED
that thank you thank you you're awesome
um yeah seriously hands hand for the
transcript
um yeah super
um and and so um the thing that I loved
about this was that as um as the editor
moves spaces with the AWS D Keys also
another key combination we're all really
familiar with right
um
the this cute this Q added QED thing
with the QED I guess is what I should
call it
um and it would output little percent
signs percent sign percent sign percent
sign so that the output of what you were
changing lined up with the previous
lines output
um you know so I just thought that was
really cool
um and it was fun and it you know it
just made me think about
um a future talk which you know we'll
get into in a minute because again
Turtles all the way down here
um all right so uh I mentioned Kim
Thompson was at Berkeley came back to
Bell Labs guess what happened right so
he wrote an implementation of QED for
Bell labs and this is the place where
the syntax comes from this paper is from
1970 it's online you can find it if you
care about it it's a really fascinating
read if you're into the history of text
editing and stuff like that
um which is also a fascinating topic
unfortunately I don't have time to get
into but um you know if you're
interested in that I can end it on its
own merits so this is a technical memory
random it's the QED user manual again
online it's by another guy you've
probably heard of Dennis Ritchie and Ken
Thompson we've already talked about him
a few times
dead is Richie I'm sure many of you are
familiar with you know co-creator of
Unix Turing Award winner blah blah super
smart guy
um anyway where does the syntax come
from it comes from here okay I just want
to run through this list really quickly
because this is all stuff that you're
going to just get your mind blown by
okay so this is the rules for regular
Expressions what's the first rule right
any ordinary character is part of a
regular expression it matches itself
okay makes sense the carrot okay matches
what beginning of the string okay a
dollar sign ins the string right dot any
character except what a new line okay
the sort of character class with the
brackets right introduced in 1970. all
right and then the whole little bracket
carrot with a class negate the class
right everything except this
um and then anything that's followed by
star is zero or more of that thing right
and then you can also do
um the alternation right two adjacent
they form a regular expression right so
you can alternate between left and right
and that that's what it talks about down
here at the bottom the pipe operator
right so
that's like 90 of what most people use
on a daily basis right 1970 amazing
um and then there's some examples in
here right these are all things that you
should recognize right
um slash ABCD right okay so the other
thing I wanted to say was where does the
slash come from it comes from here right
why do regular Expressions I are
de-marked with a slash I don't know like
they decided that's how they wanted to
be
um so yeah uh Peter Deutsch and and
Butler Lampson they like slashes and so
they just kept that when they moved it
to Bell Labs they're like okay well this
is a Unix thing now and we're gonna have
slashes too because you know that's how
that's how we roll
um but I guess my favorite example here
is you know the infamous carrot carrot
dollar
um which is what an empty line right
um I love that and then um finally
they're like at the bottom we have this
thing where it's like ABC and then the
class of any digit right so that's what
it's going to match and then it's like
ABCD followed by any not digit
okay so those are cool
um the thing that you'll notice though
and one of the refinements that came
later we're going to talk about that in
just a minute is this whole idea of a
class that's very verbose right like
every single character that's in that
class you have to enumerate it right
um that's super annoying if you're
sitting at a typewriter and you're
typing all this out like on a keyboard
um I'm sure you can imagine a typo there
would be very irritating to you
um and you know not just because like
you'd have to maybe do it over again
um but yeah there was just a lot of
typing that was required so they're like
can we do better right okay so this is
1970. mention that all right this guy
came along his name's Alfred Ajo
um you may be familiar with him too he
invented egrep uh oh one more thing I
wanted to uh mention
um super fascinating too there was uh I
didn't have time to
um make a slide for it but
the there is a
there's a mode that you could start QED
in and it will read a file before it
actually opens the buffer that you want
to edit and you could program it to do
things like said does for us right and
so people were using this all the time
they were using it all the time at Bell
labs and they started were like well
what can we decouple from this editor
why do we need to start this editor all
the time when we want to do an edit
right can't we just have one little tool
well also the other thing that this
thing was really good at was grep right
grep so there's G slash regular
expression slash P that was the syntax
to QED that made it go look at a file
find a phrase and output it onto the
teletype okay and they're like why do we
want to start this editor when all we
really want to do is see if this file
will match this regular expression can
we have a standalone tool and sure
enough they were like yeah that makes
sense let's do that and so it became
part of system five
um if you go back and look at the Unix
archive which is now on GitHub you can
see the source code for grep came right
out of this editor it's pretty fast
fascinating so anyway that's where grep
came from that's why grepp's called grab
because it's grep right makes sense
everyone
cool all right so this guy came along
and he's like you know what
um we can do better like I don't want to
type all this stuff like it's too much
and
um you know the other thing was is by
this time this is 1978 so by this time
most people are using CRTs they're not
using teletypes anymore they're still
around but they're less common and so
they started using teletypes and um you
know they have this on-screen experience
now so it's a little bit less annoying
for them
um and you know but he's like I still
don't want to type all this stuff so I'm
going to make it so that you can define
a class as like beginning character Dash
to some end character and it's like the
lexical contents of that thing right so
you can do like 0-9 or you can do a dash
Z right or you can do like capital a
dash capital Z and those will all sort
sort of in their ASCII numerical
representation right
um and so that was an innovation that he
added here and then the other part was
that he wanted to have extended syntax
um in grep so the original grab just
took a simple regular expression it
didn't have like all this other stuff in
it he's like you know what why don't we
why don't we do that and then the final
thing that he did was he wrote this
paper that I've copied out here called
efficient string matching which is super
fascinating and what it does is a very
very very fast lexical search over a
large Corpus of data so at the time a
large Corpus of data was something like
one and a half megabytes okay I know
that doesn't sound like anything now but
in 1978 that was a lot and so what he
wanted to do was be able to quickly
search through records to find strings
that matched like a bibliography or
whatever they're like hey do we already
have this on our system right we might
have to go find it or whatever so he
wrote this tool and egrep uses that
algorithm okay
um
also he recently won a touring award
which I did not know so I put that in
there I thought that was pretty
interesting um that's a um usually when
a person wins a touring award they do a
lecture
um I'm not sure he's done this yet but
they're all fascinating greeting highly
encourage you to read them
um of course he wrote awk
um many of you probably have used it I
know I have
um and then the techniques and
algorithms that he described and are
also part of egrap were used to create
this lexical parser called Lex and this
compiler compiler called Yak right so he
was responsible for a huge amount of
like pilot compiler construction Dynamic
scripting languages you know things that
are kind of cool and very groundbreaking
for 1978. okay so next slide small
digression and I'm like almost out of
time here so I'm going to keep going as
quickly as I can I have no carrot and I
must match in 1978 not everyone had the
same keyboard okay there were no
standardized keyboards in 1978 so I was
like well how are we going to match on
the beginning of line how are we going
to match on the end of line we need a
special Syntax for that so that's where
all that backslash capital a capital Z
nonsense came from is from this right
it's like all these non-standard
keyboards especially like in Europe
nothing against Europeans but you know
they don't have ASCII keyboards um and
so it was like well how are we going to
do these matches if we don't even have
these keys that are you know physically
present on our keyboard
um you just got what you got and you
were grateful for it
um and so they came up with this
alternate way to describe these uh
special signifiers
and that kind of became like the general
escape sequence for regular Expressions
right this backslash something something
all right 1978 we're done with you
goodbye
um so now it's 1986.
um there was a problem with Egret the
problem was is that it was owned by Bell
Labs okay and in the 80s again I don't
have time to go into this it's a
fascinating story there was this huge
legal fight between Berkeley and ATT
about who owned the rights to you know
distribute Unix especially after
Berkeley added a whole bunch of stuff to
it that we all take for granted now like
networking and blah blah
um anyway this guy Henry Spencer who was
at the University of Toronto wrote this
package actually posted on Usenet he was
a big Usenet Guy and um he posted this
package that was a almost bite for bite
compatible regular expression Engine
with system five's regular expression
engine and whether it was in the public
domain so what that meant was is that
all of your favorite programs now could
start using regular Expressions as a
Library without encumbering itself with
ATT legal stuff right which no one
really wanted to touch with the 10 meter
cattle prod because it was just a big
giant hairy mess and so anyway that
stuff wasn't wasn't uh settled like even
well into the 90s and again fascinating
story I don't have time to get into it
um it's pretty cool but anyway he wrote
this thing called reg up
um and then this guy took it
this is Larry wall he wrote Pearl Pearl
came out in 1987
um and you know Pearl was like one of
the first uh sort of things that stole a
whole bunch of ideas from Bash from you
know shell from awk from said all of
those things kind of mushed it all
together
anyway Pearl started out with Henry's
regular expression library and over time
Larry and other people in the pearl
Community munged it right and eventually
what we ended up with is this maximalist
regex right too much is never enough
okay that is the Pearl approach to
almost everything right it's like uh
there there's you know and I'm an old
Pearl nerd too so you know because I'm
of a certain vintage and um but but yeah
so maximal regex maximalist everything
Tim Toady the white there's more than
one way to do it blah blah blah that's
the Pearl way
um so anyway
um what happened after that is this guy
another guy
um really fascinating
um uh his name is I've forgotten I'm
sorry I've forgotten um but he wrote
this this pcre package I'm so sorry pcre
of author I've forgotten your name um he
worked at the University of Cambridge
and he wrote this pcre package because
he wrote the XM mail transfer agent and
he wanted to use Pearl compatible
regular expressions in that right and
people asked him to do that so he wrote
this library and released it as its own
thing it turns out that actually was the
more interesting thing for everyone else
not the not the MTA but the regular
expression thing
um gosh I'm really running out of time
so I'm just going to zoom through these
last few things so pcre and pearl use
this thing called NFA okay and now we're
using NFA in sort of a generic sense
which means that it's a breadth first
search through the search base okay it's
recursive and it looks back and it does
backtracking so if it doesn't find a
match it goes back to the last state
that was valid and it moves forward
again trying to find the biggest match
that it possibly can okay it's all
really well described in this paragraph
unfortunately I have time to get into it
but
in 19 in 2007 Russ Cox wrote this um
post that's out on the internet called
um that regex can be matching can be
really fast and safe but it isn't and
this the the graphs here if I can just
quickly go over this and again I'm
almost out of time so I'm just going to
zoom through this so over here you have
literal seconds okay and you can see as
the terms Crea increased to 30
um Pearl's time becomes exponential in
seconds and then over here we have Russ
Cox's hand-coded Thompson algorithm this
is in microseconds and and you can see
that is literally ten thousand ten
million times faster than Pearl
foreign
so he was like what the hell people like
what's your what's your problem why are
we doing regex like this like have you
learned nothing right he's grabbing you
by the shoulders and shaking you have
you learned nothing okay so this was
2007 in 2010 he wrote this Library
called re2 re2 got part of of go link
and Ross was like a big part of go
Lang's um you know group that kind of
formed a lot of standards and things
like that
so what did he write ru2 for it's
exactly because I showed you that last
Slide the concern that he had was people
can give us really pathologically bad
regular Expressions especially if it's
like untested input from random people
and I want to make sure that like my
Computing resources are safely Bound by
some sort of you know limit on
computation and um you know so he wrote
this Library called re2 and this is why
golang has the regular Expressions that
it does anyway this is a a um a
um
not a depth first but breath first
search across the search space and it
doesn't do any backtracking okay so if
it doesn't find a match it's done right
it's like nope this isn't a match I'm
finished
um and it doesn't have like a back ex
back references and a whole bunch of
other things that people in Pearl wanted
and most people still want but anyway um
it's really interesting uh there's a
whole blog post about it's in the
bibliography for my slide deck so in
summary in summary regular Expressions
originated from mathematics right the
implementations came from editors and
from compilers Unix provided facilities
to use regex and tools which is how we
got them Ock provided a way for people
to trigger actions in Dynamic scripting
languages Pearl added a bunch of
features that people liked until they
didn't like them and that's all the time
I have thank you very much
[Applause]